ich wollte von meinem lieblingswerbespot
sein ankel Breis da hat der die
Werbefigur von er schwarzer das ist ist
da V eine so orage Packung links um so
Kreis da ist der werbemann drin der kkel
Ben praktisch so ganzer freundlicher
schwarz mit so große Kulla Augen und der
in Kamera geschaut und hat er gesagt
klebrige und klumpige R das kann der
beste Haus passieren diesen Werbespot
den kannst du Hal nichtmer bringen die
Firma W den ernsthaft würde die Krieg
einen schitm Krieg die ab D sie die nie
wieder davorher holen na die müss
Heizung kbge und klumpige R das kann die
beste Hausfrau und dem besten Hausmann
passieren na Schmarn Schmarn er Song
klebrige und klumpige R das kann der
beste Hausfrau den besten Hausmann und
der besten diversen Person passieren